[Música]
y llegó la hora de los deportes en
france 24 de la compañía de nuestro
compañero luís méndez luis bienvenido de
nuevo al estudio comencemos por las
noticias del atletismo porque ya está
todo listo para el inicio de los
campeonatos mundiales en oregón eeuu así
es maría clara y en la previa nuestra
vida especial juan josé sayago conversó
con la campeona olímpica del triple
salto en la venezolana yulimar rojas
escuchemos si de alguien se habla en el
mundial de atletismo es de la reina del
salto triple yulimar rojas con quien
tuvimos la posibilidad de conversar
acerca de lo que será su prueba del
triple salto y de la información que
surgió en los últimos días de su no
participación en el salto largo vamos a
escuchar lo que nos dijo judy más rojas
acerca de su participación en oregón
2022 quiero dejar
una gran actuación que quiero
dar lo mejor de mí no quedarme con
dejarlo todo en la pista si os venía que
yo yo venía con una marca hecha pero al
final y a última hora me da me le
invalidaron por temas de
normas de reglas que hay en el tema de
la zapatilla había compartido con esta
partida de triple salto y esa norma se
implementó el año pasado que que todo
aquel que compita en un salto largo con
zapatilla de triple salto su marca no no
no van a estar validada porque el grosor
de la de las zapatillas de salto triple
cinco centímetros más que la de salto
largo uno de los hitos importantes para
la venezolana en este evento es el de
conseguir la tercera medalla de oro de
manera consecutiva en campeonatos
mundiales en el salto triple hablamos
por supuesto de campeonatos mundiales
autor
yulimar se convertiría en la primera
atleta en la historia en conseguir este
importante galardón quiero seguir con la
racha que llevo de títulos ganados
y eso para mí
es más importante que
incluso que hay que saltar por arriba de
1560 sin duda que el legado de yulimar
rojas es algo impresionante lo que pueda
dejar acá en ahora con no solamente a
nivel de medallas sino a seguir
construyendo una leyenda alrededor de
quién es sin duda la atleta más
importante en la historia de venezuela